bonjour on commence avec la situation
dans les Deux-Sèvres près de
Sainte-Soline c'est un weekend de
manifestation pourtant interdites contre
les réserves de substitution c'est
retenu d'eau au profit des agriculteurs
les opposants appellent ça des des
bassines ce matin 8h21 quel message
voulez-vous adresser à ces manifestants
au moment où il s'apprête à se réunir oh
un message de responsabilité
d'apaisement mais qui est dans leur main
la vérité c'était manifestation qui ont
été interdites non pas pour le
plaisir d'interdire des manifestations
mais les éléments qu'on en a sont des
éléments qui laissent à penser
d'ailleurs on a vu les saisies qui ont
été fait hier de gens qui avaient qui
des machettes qui DH qui diffusaient de
détresse on l'a vu ce qui s'était passé
aussi au mois de novembre
qui manifestement pour un certain nombre
d'entre jamais je fais d'amalgame mais
pour un certain nombre parce que pour
info pour un peu vous allez nous dire
que la foule n'est pas légitime là-bas
je disais je fais pas d'amalgame mais je
dis que quand vous saisissez des gens
qui ont des machettes et des et des SDH
je crois pas que ce soit des
manifestants et quand vous pensez que
vous en avez 1000 dans une foule qui est
estimé assez ou 10000 vous avez des
risques à l'ordre public qui justifient
l'interdiction de manifester il y a 3000
gendarmes ce qui est beaucoup mais ce
qui est aussi face à des gens très
déterminé et qui ne pensent pas la vie
humaine comme un bien précieux
c'est quand même une grande mobilisation
pour les gendarmes il faut saluer
l'action de la préfète de ce département
et des forces de l'ordre des forces de
sécurité pour essayer de faire en sorte
que c'est des choses se passent sans
qu'il y ait trop de violence et donc
c'est un appel à la fois à ça difficile
de parler à ceux qui se promènent avec
des h et des machettes parce que vous
voyez bien que je suis pas sûr que la
parole performerait si on peut dire mais
pour les autres ceux qui ne sont pas
dans cette dans ce registre là qui
essaye de dire des choses leur dire que
d'abord c'est une manifestation
interdite et donc y compris pour eux
vis-à-vis de gens qui sont très violents
il y a des risques et ça n'empêche pas
qu'on puisse ne pas être d'accord avec
tel ou tel projet et puis deuxième
élément leur dire que quand même c'est
un projet on peut discuter aussi du fond
d'ailleurs mais qui barre bien les
aspects y compris dans le processus qui
a amené à la construction de ses
réserves et plutôt exemplaire en termes
de discussion de débat ça a amené un
protocole qui a été signé par des
associations environnementales par des
élus au premier rang desquels madame
bateau qui ont retiré ensuite leur
signature et moi quand j'appose une
signature quelque part j'essaie de le
faire avec avec recul et donc le process
lui-même
est un process ou rien n'était imposé du
haut les choses se sont faites sur le
terrain avec les associations locales
avec les agriculteurs locaux avec les
services de l'État les services
scientifiques sur les questions d'eau et
donc il faut aussi regarder comme ce
projet comme exemplaire dans sa démarche
et là vous calmez le jeu mais il y a des
ministres c'est toujours en température
au sein du même gouvernement que vous
qui qu'on qu'on met un peu d'huile sur
le feu je pense à Gérald Darmanin qui
assure qu'il s'agira d'une grande
mobilisation de l'extrême gauche venu
s'en prendre au gendarmes pour peut-être
les tuer ou tuer les institutions vous
partagez ce genre de propos dans les
milles que je viens qui sont identifiés
ou comme tel il y a manifestent ce genre
des gens qui sont dans ce registre là je
peux pas en quoi ça serait orthogonal
tout à fait dire ça et dire en même
temps pour les autres pour ceux qui qui
pensent des choses sur ces sujets là qui
de bonne foi pensent différemment de ce
que les uns et les autres peuvent penser
cela c'est pas les mêmes donc c'est
l'extrême gauche en ce moment les 1000
qu'on a c'est des éléments qui viennent
qui de Suisse qui d'Italie qui
d'Allemagne qui de Belgique et qui
manifestement ne sont pas autre chose
que des gens rompus
service de manifestation plutôt que la C
à l'extrême gauche et effectivement
qu'il faudra que violence
et c'est pas une provocation que de
décrire simplement une réalité en
l'occurrence Yannick Jadot disait qu'il
y a en ce moment une criminalisation
finalement permanente criminer les
actions des militants écologistes non
c'est tout à fait inexact monsieur Jadot
d'Orelsan d'ailleurs alors on essaie
d'exister comment on peut parfois mais
inutile de chercher des choses
compliquées il a criminalisation c'est
pas ça la criminalisation c'est quand
vous faites des actes qui sont
répréhensibles d'inversion pas les
choses personne ici n'est en Bastille
dans ce pays sans que la justice ne soit
pas passée sans qu'il y a des actes de
procédure parfois d'ailleurs j'entends
même dans le monde agricole des gens qui
trouvent que nous n'allons pas assez
loin et moi je tiens la position que la
justice doit passer mais la justice dans
les formes de droit et l'état de droit
dans lequel nous sommes donc je trouve
que c'est une caricature en revanche
quand vous allez détruire le bien
d'autrui oui ça relève d'une oui c'est
un délit alors dans le fond du dossier
pour le gouvernement et pour vous en
particulier Marc féno pas de moratoire
autour de ces projets de réserve qui
pourraient continuer pas de moratoire
juste en deux minutes les choses sur ce
projet sainte Soline c'est quoi c'est à
date en 2018 avant que nous soit signé
le protocole 21 millions de mètres cubes
prélevés sur le sur le sur ce périmètre
là le protocole il prévoit de plus en
prélever qu'environ 12 millions 12
millions 5 dans ces 12 millions de ne
plus en prélever que 6 millions l'été
les 21 millions étaient prévus l'été
donc 21 6 millions de mètres cubes
prélevés donc on a une réduction
drastique des prélèvements en été
qu'elle est la période la plus cruciale
et on fait des réserves environ 6
millions de mètres cubes pour pouvoir
les remplir pour qu'elles puissent être
utilisés les thés mais rempli par des
eaux divers quand il y a de l'eau hiver
d'ailleurs à ceux qui disent bah cette
année elles sont moins remplies d'abord
elles sont plutôt remplies dans ce
secteur là mais si elles sont moins
remplies bah il y aura pas il y aura pas
de prélèvement parce que la nappe
permettra pas de prélever deuxième
élément on a des agriculteurs qui sont
engagés sur des diagnostics pour toutes
les exploitations collectifs et
individuelles des engagements
individuels c'est-à-dire qu'elles
agriculteurs qui signent en bas d'un
papier des engagements sur réduction des
indices de traitement il y a un suivi de
ça il y a un compte bien sûr il y a un
suivi et dans quelques jours on donnera
le suivi mais je peux vous dire par
exemple que les surfaces en bio se sont
très largement développées je peux vous
dire que l'indice de fréquence de
traitement c'est-à-dire le nombre de
fois on traite les parcelles c'est
réduit de façon très importante il y a
des gens qui plantent des donc il y a
des engagements précis et suivis qui
sont mis en place alors j'entends
certains dire oui mais on sait pas s'ils
vont tenir les engagements mais on vit
dans un état et à la fois de droite ce
que je rappelais tout à l'heure aussi un
état de responsabilité on doit se faire
confiance moi j'estime que quand
quelqu'un signe en bas d'un papier il
est engagé non seulement vis-à-vis de
l'État mais il est engagé vis-à-vis de
la collectivité et là vous avez des
agriculteurs qui sont engagés et on est
dans un cycle qui est plutôt vertueux
puisque au final il y aura d'ailleurs le
le bureau de recherche géologique et
minières
je dis plus bien parce que vous avez
raison il faut le dire
qui travaille sur les nappes comme vous
le savez lui il dit que ses vertueux
parce qu'il y aura plus d'eau en été
dans les cours d'eau sauf que le BRGM
dit aussi que c'est nappe fasse pas
danser retenu d'eau pourraient très bien
ne plus être rempli par manque d'eau
dans notre prochaine vidéo vous êtes
peut-être en train de construire des
piscines qui ne serv non c'est inexact
il dit ils disent que dans certaines
années elles pourront être à plein de
pas être remplies oui mais je vous
explique un truc vous mettre des je
prends une comparaison vous mettez des
dispositifs antigel dans les vignes ça
couvre le riz jusqu'à -2 - 3 - 4 quand
ça fait -8 ou moins 10 ça ne couvre pas
le risque sauf que ça couvre le riz dans
les périodes les plus les plus communes
et dans les périodes les plus intenses
oui ben si elles ne peuvent pas être
remplies ne peuvent pas être remplies
mais c'est bien l'objectif des ouvrages
que d'avoir cette fonction-là plutôt
d'assurance si je peux dire là on parle
de sainte solide mais ouvrons un peu le
dossier il y a combien de bassines enfin
de grandes réserves d'eau aujourd'hui en
France je peux pas vous dire il y a des
centaines et des milliers de réserves
d'eau sous des formes diverses un des
étangs
non mais là je parle de réserve d'eau de
méga bassines de je sais pas ce que
c'est j'ai du mal à vous dire ce que
c'est qu'une méga bassine c'est combien
d'hectares une méga bassine j'ai des
étangs Solène chez moi ils font 10
hectares
c'est un méga étant et serpent son c'est
quoi c'est une méga méga méga mega mega
mega mega je trouve que dans la
terminologie je fais pas de reproche à
la terminologie mais des projets de
cette nature là je peux pas vous les
quantifier donc je vais pas vous dire
les questions c'est il en faut plus ou
pas mais ça dépend ça dépend des
territoires il y a des endroits oui il y
a des endroits il en faudra plus il faut
assumer cette mais parfois c'est des
bacille
la solution ce sont ces je vais essayer
de vous expliquer après parfois c'est
des retenues colinaires parfois c'est
des ouvrages plus grands types type ceux
qui sont dans le Verdon donc il y a pas
de c'est pour ça que la question n'est
pas la quantité en tant que telle de
telle ou tel type d'ouvrage alors
qu'est-ce que je dis et qu'est-ce que
nous disons et qu'est-ce que nous allons
dire
je vous donne des chiffres 500 milliards
de mètres cubes qui tombent d'eau chaque
année 300 milliards sont utilisés
naturellement par la plante il en reste
200 milliards dans les 200 milliards il
en est prélevé 33 9 sont réellement
prélevés là-dessus il y en a trois qui
sont prélevés par l'agriculture 3
milliards je sais pas 300 puisque le
reste est utile 3 200 on a besoin de
quoi on a besoin de combiner à la fois
des réserves de substitution des
réserves des retenues collinaires enfin
toutes les formes de retenues qu'on peut
avoir pour pallier à la période où on a
besoin le plus d'eau et on a besoin par
ailleurs de faire en sorte que Alexa on
appelle moins d'eau on est besoin de
moins d'eau changement de culture
variétés plus résistantes à l'eau
système d'irrigation disent que ça va
c'est beaucoup d'eau qui va servir à une
minorité d'explorateurs d'exploitants
agricoles en maïs mais ça ça veut rien
pardon excusez-moi
c'est des ex d'exploitation qui font
entre 100 et 150 hectares c'est pas des
méga exploitations parce que tous ces
termes-là veulent plus rien dire non
mais au moment où les nappes phréatiques
envie de vous entendez
on est entre ce que vous n'avez entendu
dire autre chose que on a besoin d'eau
en agriculture donc il faut qu'on
prévoit les périodes on a moins d'eau
dans la rythmique climatique et on a
besoin de sobriété en agriculture c'est
à dire d'avoir des pratiques agricoles
qui fassent qu'à l'hectare qu'elle a
tonne de matière organique produites on
est besoin de moins d'eau et je dis les
pratiques agricoles les variétés doivent
changer doivent évoluer et donc c'est
les deux vous allez dans cette
territoire ne parle pas beaucoup des
nappes phréatiques or ce matin ce qui
est choquant c'est ça c'est c'est
encore les nappes phréatiques pardon de
d'être de faire dans la nuance la nappe
phréatique de Beauce celle que je
connais le mieux elle est une approfonde
qui se remplit l'hiver et qui se remplit
très lentement donc il faut beaucoup
d'eau pendant longtemps les nappes
phréatiques dont on parle là se
remplissent très vite et ce vide très
vite donc c'est pas du tout et donc elle
se vit très vite ça veut dire qu'elles
vont très vite à la mer on n'est pas sur
les mêmes types de nappes donc tout va
bien on n'a pas entendu dire ça je dis
juste que si on pouvait dans ce sujet là
essayez d'abord de se mettre d'accord
sur une forme de compromis sur les
besoins d'eau en agriculture
sur la nécessité de sobriété en
agriculture parce que les agriculteurs
qui m'écoutent et ceux qui m'écoutent
globalement ils savent qu'il fallait
qu'il faut de la sobriété et que ici
c'est moins de maïs ici c'est des
cultures qui vont évoluer ici c'est des
variétés qui seront plus résistants ici
c'est des pratiques qui permettent
d'avoir de la matière organique et tenir
l'eau dans le sol c'est tout ça qui
conduit dans le protocole de
sainte-souligne il y a de la plantation
de la plantation de s à plusieurs vertus
au delà de la biodiversité qui est une
grande vertu une deuxième vertu c'est de
la voiture ça contient l'eau vous voyez
bien qu'il y a un plan qui a été pensé
et donc c'est pas parce qu'on remplit
pas les nappes phréatiques en plein
hiver comme en ce moment où elles sont
encore parce que en ce moment c'est
comme ça mais personne ne sait si moi je
me souviens 2016 il est très sec et
après j'avais 85 cm d'eau dans la
commune dont j'étais le maire donc
attention à ne pas il faut raisonner sur
le temps long les surfaces en irrigation
en France je le rappelle c'est 7% des
surfaces de France
personne ne dit qu'on va passer à 90% et
certainement pas moi on a sans doute
besoin dans certains territoires d'un
peu plus d'eau mais globalement il faut
que ça soit sobre tout ça allez on
change de dossier monsieur le ministre
de l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire il y a l'eau il y a aussi
les pesticides l'INRA et vient de
publier cette semaine une étude qui
envisage d'épices pour se passer
complètement de pesticides d'ici 2050
avez-vous pris connaissance de cette
étude et qu'elle conclusion en
tirez-vous j'ai pris connaissance de
cette étude dans laquelle il fait moi je
trouve toujours un bon travail au fond à
moyen et long terme et là on est plutôt
sur le long terme elle pose des
hypothèses dont on voit bien que
elle-même posée pose une difficulté
majeure pour y arriver et c'est pas
attendez c'est pas parce que je dis ça
qu'il faut pas se mettre sur un chemin
de réduction des produits
phytosanitaires mais vous voyez bien que
2025 en 2023 ça m'a pas échappé mais
2025 disons 2050 en 25 ans ce mouvement
là il est long mais ce qu'on dit sur
l'agriculture pardon de le dire c'est
valable sur le logement c'est valable
sur la construction c'est valable sur on
a besoin de transition qui sont longues
et moi ce que j'en lis c'est qu'il y a
des choses qu'on peut faire il y a des
choses qui sont plus difficiles à faire
il y a des choses qui sont adaptes les
drap edit il faut diversifier les
cultures il faut pourquoi pas
très bien c'est ce qu'on a financier
relance la robotique changer les codes
de la politique agricole commune oui
mais on a une politique agricole commune
qui sera révisée en 2027 puis revisez
ensuite donc il donne des clés et des
éléments mais pour faire une transition
comme ça il faut du temps et ils disent
aussi que c'est un objectif
qui n'est pas atteignable comme ça
et c'est bien qu'on se dise que les
objectifs il suffit pas de claquer des
doigts parce que j'entendais des gens
qui me disaient faut interdire les
néonicotinoïdes c'est simple résultat
cette année je me retrouve avec une
filière on m'avait dit il y a des
affaires
et donc si on pouvait se dire qu'on a
besoin de transition qui a des choses
possibles et que parfois il y a encore
les produits phytosanitaires parce que
c'est utile et que de la chimie il y en
a partout il y en a dans ce bureau dans
ce studio il y en a chez vous il y en a
chez moi il y en a donc aussi en
agriculture et que on peut essayer d'en
sortir on peut essayer de la réduire
mais aussi on peut en avoir besoin
marquez nous parlons aussi du contexte
actuel dans lequel on est la visite la
visite du roi Charles III a donc été
repoussé on l'a appris hier reporté
probablement à l'été prochain est-ce que
c'est le signe peut-être d'un président
qui commence à reconnaître qu'il y a
peut-être un problème avec sa réforme
des retraites c'est le signe d'un
président qui est à l'écoute en tout cas
je il est à l'écoute il est à l'écoute
de ce qu'est l'opinion et qui est de ce
qu'est d'abord on a des forces de
sécurité qui sont beaucoup mobilisées et
donc les mobilisés pour un événement
supplémentaire reconnaissant que il peut
y avoir quelque chose que peu de gens
pourraient il faut saluer les forces de
l'ordre qui sont extrêmement mobilisées
et qui sont très sollicités
et donc que dans ce contexte là on
puisse reporter une visite qui est une
visite d'État
qui est celle du roi Charles moi ça me
paraît logique ça me paraît normal et ça
me paraît une décision qui est celle qui
emprunte de bon sens et en adéquation
avec le moment qu'on traverse c'est
normal mais ça montre aussi que la
stratégie du pourrissement sur laquelle
Paris l'Elysée montre ses limites
mais j'ai du mal à entendre ce sera ce
mot de pourrissement le pourrissement
c'est l'idée qu'on ne la stratégie se
dire on va à l'usure on les aura mais
c'est pas ça dans cette y compris dans
cette affaire de référendum mais c'est
un peu ce qu'il a dit lors de
l'interview qu'il a accordé il y a 3
jours mercredi en disant cette réforme
on l'a enjambée maintenant on est passé
au coup d'après et bien non pas tout je
moi je n'ai pas vu comme ça mais peu
importe je veux dire ce que je pense moi
j'ai pas dit qu'on l'a enjambé je peux
pas nier ce qui s'est passé ce qui se
passe dans la rue faut pas nier la
colère que ça a pu susciter il faut pas
nier les inquiétudes des interrogations
les incompréhensions il faut pas dire
que c'est pas les gens qui ont les gens
comprennent mal c'est nous qui avons
sans doute mal expliqué un certain
nombre de choses notamment que cette
réforme n'était pas une réforme
populaire par nature et pas agréable par
nature puisque c'est une il s'agit
d'allonger la durée mais ça les Français
ont bien compris au travail et ça des
gens oui mais dans les mots il faut le
dire il vaut mieux poser les choses mais
on l'a fait pourquoi parce qu'on
considère
je peux débattre avec tout le long du
sujet mais on considère que l'intérêt du
pays les tiré incompré en termes de
souveraineté financière c'est qu'on est
des comptes qui soient mieux équilibrés
et donc c'est pas la question du
pourrissement c'est la question que
cette réforme elle est nécessaire non
mais pourrissement on a le sentiment que
c'est la violence vers laquelle on est
en train de tendre qui va peut-être
faire bouger le président non je crois
pas vous avez entendu aussi ce qu'il a
dit hier en sortie de conseil européen
en disant qu'il considérait que la
violence était inacceptable parce que si
vous accrédité la thèse c'est pas une
question de tourisme là si vous
accrédité la thèse que c'est par la
violence que vous obtenez droit à un
certain nombre de demandes qu'elle soit
légitimes ou pas enfin légitime au sens
démocratique alors à ce moment-là vous
êtes dans une société qui n'est plus une
société démocratique donc la violence ne
peut pas avoir le pas sur le reste c'est
aussi simple que ça à Sainte-Soline
comme dans notre liste mais là non plus
les gens qui manifestent le million de
gens qui ont manifesté
la semaine dernière c'est c'est
majoritairement des gens qui sont contre
la réforme c'est pas des gens qui sont
violents donc essayons de distingués de
la violence de la part d'un certain de
manifestants il y a de la violence aussi
du côté des forces de l'ordre on a
entendu ce matin à plusieurs reprises
dans les journaux de France Inter ces
policiers de la brave m qui insultent
qui humilie certaines personnes
interpellées elles sont fatiguées comme
dit Gérald Darmanin ses forces de
l'ordre quand elle commettent ces
bavures policières alors d'abord moi
j'ai été s'il s'avérer que c'était bien
ce qu'on nous décrit moi je suis
toujours par nature pour tout le monde
d'ailleurs on attend les filles il y a
une enquête qui est en cours mais s'il
s'avère que c'est vrai c'est extrêmement
choquant et c'est même plus ce que
choquant parce que la police et la
gendarmerie les forces de l'ordre les
tiennes ce qu'on appelle le pôle de la
violence légitime parce qu'elle procède
de ce que doit être un intérêt général
il faut identifier les gens aussi il
faut les interroger enfin pardon faisons
demandons à faire pour la police que
font pour le vous et moi
c'est pour ça que j'ai pas de prudence
verbale en tant que tel je dis juste
faut que laisser se dérouler l'enquête
c'était il y a deux ou trois jours si
j'ai bien compris mais c'est
effectivement très choquant et je
comprends tout à fait l'état de fatigue
de policiers et de gendarmes qui sont
chargés de maintien d'or dans des
conditions qui sont très difficiles
parce que vous avez au milieu d'une
foule qui est complètement pacifique des
gens qui viennent mettre le la pagaille
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'ils peuvent
en tirer parce que comme ils sont au
milieu d'une foule pacifique et que
c'est plus compliqué d'aller les
chercher dans une foule Pacifique
évidemment c'est plus compliqué mais ça
ne justifiera jamais
des comportements individuels qui soient
des comportements qui ne sont pas
conformes ni à l'éthique ni à la loi
d'ailleurs ni à l'esprit de la loi en
termes de maintien de l'ordre et
reconnaissons qu'il y a eu beaucoup de
manifestations depuis le mois de janvier
on a le mois de décembre et que dans la
plupart des cas les choses se sont
passées dans de bonnes conditions faut
aussi saluer d'ailleurs les services
d'ordre des syndicats quels sont des
solutions maintenant on en sorte comment
tout ça le président de la République a
demandé à ce que nous réfléchissons nous
ministres autour de la première ministre
à ce que pourrait être aidé message et
des dossiers que nous pourrions mettre
sur la table il me semble qu'on a besoin
de
de rendre visible ce qu'on fait je pense
qu'on a besoin de rendre visible aussi
ce qu'il faut ce dont les gens ont
besoin d'un point de vue concret je vous
donne un seul exemple je pense que le
sujet
maintes fois itérer du médical le sujet
de santé est un sujet qui saisit
l'ensemble des Français et nous avons
tous autour de nous des gens qui n'ont
pas de médecin référents n'arrivent pas
à trouver un spécialiste dans des délais
qui sont dans ce genre de retraites
on a une réforme des retraites j'ai
essayé de vous dire en quelques mots ce
que je pensais de la nécessité de la
faire et de la nécessité pour les pays
en termes de souveraineté ça ceci étant
posé ça n'empêche pas que j'ai des
sujets moi j'ai beaucoup de gens qui
m'ont dit j'ai des sujets de pouvoir
d'achat j'ai des sujets d'accès à la
santé c'est aussi des sujets concrets
pour les gens le gouvernement veut
j'allais dire faire diversion mais c'est
pourtant bien le chef de l'État qui
cristallise en ce moment la contestation
mais nous sommes dans un pays moi je
suis toujours très frappé quand il y a
un problème dans un pays c'est et
qu'est-ce que fait le chef de l'État et
qu'est-ce que fait le Président c'est
d'ailleurs pas nouveau j'ai toujours
entendu ça ça fait 25 ans que je suis
dans la politique c'est toujours on est
un pays qui rêve de décentralisation et
que et dès qu'il y a un problème c'est
que fait le gouvernement et gouvernement
égal chef de l'État non mais il avait
laissé Elisabeth borde en première ligne
pendant les débats l'assemblée ça a été
adopté dans les conditions qu'on le sait
maintenant c'est l'objet de l'État qui
cristallise la contestation ça se
termine toujours comme ça je trouve
d'ailleurs plutôt on va pas lui
reprocher à la fois de de se cacher
certains font ça et d'autres d'être en
première ligne vous êtes le milieu de la
consiste à 11h de l'État il assume sa
responsabilité il était élu par le
peuple français ce qui est différent de
ce que nous sommes au gouvernement et
donc par construction il vient polariser
dans un pays qui se rêve encore un peu
centralisé ou qui est un peu encore
centralisé Marc féno le ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire était ce matin notre invité